we're all in a heist right now we're all
prepping for a heist who's holding what
role can I be the ideas guy see he's on
the computer he's like hold on hold on
I'm in this direction in the red dress
Ryan's the Italian guy that bumps into
you and he's like hey I'm walking here
but then he walk away and he's like
sleight of hand pickpocket dicks the guy
who's sweating in the Elevator Shaft is
trying to get through and he's like come
on guys give me another minute and wipe
my [__] hand like oh [__] [__]
codes this is not what's on my head I'm
like the homeless guy that looks like
he's a part of the city Joe's naked
pushing the basket he's beating off and
then we're like Joe you're supposed to
be the point guy Joe's like what oh [__]
I'm jerking off out here now we have
everybody on the outside there's nobody
on the inside Joe but you're not jerking
off in the park you're the point man
you're going into the safe because
somebody has to steal the jewels and he
goes so then I jerk off after we all
gave ourselves rolls except for the guy
who takes the actual jokes to what cans
in there going like this [__]
deleting all the footage of all the
cameras in the [__] building bar was
the point man but then Bart's like nah I
gotta protect her to bed